I love music and I love entertaining get
ready because Lindsay Lohan is about to
release new music
it's about anxiety and pressure and just
taking care of yourself and I think
that's really really cool I think
there's a really cool message behind it
Cris paid teased a snippet of Lilo's new
track on Wednesdays episode of the Criss
fade show
[Music]
it's
and get this the title of the song is
xanax try stay away from you but you get
me high person in this
yes I can take launch it for the night
Chris only played about 30 seconds of
the song but he did tease that the song
is quote set to be released very very
soon it's crazy but it's great that's
really exciting Lindsey has been
dropping clues about the tune for a
while now in June she tweeted that she
was hard at work after reading a report
claiming new music was on the way and in
May she posted this pic of herself in
the studio it's been over a decade since
the rumor singer released new music but
she has been pretty busy these days she
debuted Lindsey Lohan's beach club on
MTV I started with the night lemon
Athens and because I wanted to open
doors up to people having fun and going
out at night we wanted to see how that
went in Athens that was really
successful so I said well I love the
beach and I'd rather do something in the
day now so mikonos was convenient same
partners and so was it just happened and
also signed on as a judge for the masked
singer Australia it's a lot at once when
et caught up with Lindsey in January she
teased the possibility of a duet with
her little sister Allie
your multitasking a lot what about music
my sister singing right now so I really
want to support her and that we were
just talking about this first single
just came out and do something together
yeah we've talked about that yeah her
and I talked about that my song bossy is
the song for the show but that's
something we've talked about her name
[Music]